you not only star a co-star in duck
butter you co-wrote the script I did
with Miguel Arteta
yeah can you give us a quick synopsis of
what the story is about yes it's about
two women who meet and decide to kind of
bypass normal ways of dating by spending
24 hours together having sex every hour
on the hour Wow yeah women having sex
yeah no that's fine I could see why a
man wasn't included in that I'd be good
for the first leg I'd be there for like
a few minutes up top then I'd be like I
gotta go I got a run rehydrate check
into a spa relax yeah exactly you know
it was originally written for a guy oh
really okay it was and then we just had
a hard time finding the right guy I
don't if there's a guy out there that
can once an hour for 24 hours I was
never asked to audition Kona
yeah
Wow yeah that's that would be that would
be difficult there'll be a challenge
yeah definitely but we found the right
you know person liya Costa who's this
amazing actress and when we met her we
were just like she's more right for the
part than any guy and it kind of solved
a lot of our yeah logistics of having a
penis on set yeah I never allow a penis
on set no more Annie and I have been
fixed are you you must be because you
co-wrote this project this is not
something that you found yourself cast
in you create it helped create this
reality you must be very comfortable
with then being nude or you know being
comfortable with your body and all that
yeah to a degree as much as any human is
I guess but um well they were definitely
degree there are definitely degrees with
people who are comfortable and then a
bowl yeah well the movies is very
personal to me I guess like in the way
of how we have a hard time being
comfortable with somebody and actually
being ourselves and how we think in
intimacy we're like I'm just going to
show you everything gross about me and
then someone does and you're like
actually never mind I don't like that so
that's what the movie is about and part
of that is yeah being nude and
vulnerable with somebody but on this one
I didn't feel uncomfortable about it at
all it was like such a safe set and by
the end of the day I was just like
peeing in front of the crew I was like
so what's the next shot what are we
doing like it was just so so relaxed
yeah you won't get that crew back you
guys we're all right we're good
you